elle est américaine mesure un mètre 30
et pèse près de 124 kg une bombe de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale va être
neutralisée dimanche prochain 79 ans
après son largage sur la base militaire
de tours alors occupée par les Allemands
les préparatifs de cette destruction
avait lieu hier un périmètre de sécurité
a d'ailleurs été mis en place à Tours
Nord le temps des opérations plus
d'explications avec Clémence dosc
le boulevard Abel Gand c'est la rue
Arthur Rimbaud était inaccessible ce
dimanche 19 février au matin une dizaine
de policiers quadrillés les accès au
rond-point de l'aéroport et d'Emmaüs un
périmètre de sécurité de 400 mètres a
été établie autour de la base aérienne
705 pour le désamorçage d'une bombe
d'aviation ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui c'est que nous avons
réouvert le sarcophage de cette bombe et
nous y avons pesé un détonateur explosif
et nous l'avons recouverte et c'est
véritablement cette période là qui est
la période la plus sensible ou à ce
moment-là sur zone il y avait
véritablement que trois personnes pour
limiter au maximum les risques sur le
terrain aux côtés des militaires les
équipes de l'entreprise privée des
mintech la prudence était de mise pour
cette opération de dépollution
écologique et pyrotechnique
ça fait ça se fait manuellement et les
explosifs sont sous la forme c'est comme
une pâte à modeler en fait et c'est
modeler à la main et ils viennent le
poser délicatement à la main sur la
bombe en appuyant légèrement pour que ça
reste collé sur la bombe mais c'est
vraiment manuel effectivement dater de
la Seconde Guerre mondiale la bombe a
été découverte en décembre dernier suite
à des fouilles en vue d'un chantier de
construction de bureau la basse
s'apprête à accueillir 200 personnels
administratifs d'ici l'été 2024 les 200
de la base aérienne c'est principalement
les ressources humaines du service de
santé des armées puisque vous savez que
pour les armées tours et le centre
névralgique la plaque le pôle des
ressources humaines pour reprendre un
point de vue des effectifs le système
dames des armées qui sont les hommes et
les femmes qui la constitue en 2024 nous
avons retrouvé exactement les mêmes
effectifs que nous avions en 2019
l'explosion de l'engin se fera le
dimanche 27 février un périmètre de 130
mètres sera établi et ne dépassera pas
la base aérienne les riverains
pourraient entendre une détonation
étouffée l'explosif étant recouvert de
sable